mais d'abord l'actualité donc Florent et
ce climat délétère à l'école Jean Zay de
Vendôme stupeur lundi des parents quatre
enseignantes sur cinq étaient absentes
pour le jour de la rentrée elles le sont
toujours elles entendent ainsi dénoncer
le harcèlement de certains parents mais
la situation pourrait rapidement trouver
un dénouement avec la radiation d'une
famille Faustine Luneau
une équipe pédagogique angoissée au
point que quatre enseignants de sur cinq
dont la directrice ont décidé de ne pas
se présenter à leur poste pour cette
première semaine de cours c'est ainsi
que s'est passé la rentrée à l'école
Jean Zay à Vendôme en cause un climat de
conflits entretenu par des parents
d'élèves pour le maire pas question de
laisser la situation perdurer les
tentatives de médiation ayant échoué il
a décidé de radier une famille de
l'école
quand vous avez conflit entre deux
parties
la première chose ici c'est dialogue le
dialogue vraisemblablement une fin
d'année n'aboutit à rien on recommence
l'année on voit bien que le dialogue
n'est plus possible
à un moment il faut juste éviter que les
deux parties se côtoient parce que on a
une équipe pédagogique on a des agents
municipaux à protéger et au-delà de ça
on a des enfants dans cette école une
décision exceptionnelle que peut prendre
le maire si le conflit n'est pas dû à un
élève des trois enfants de la famille
concernés seront désormais scolarisés à
l'école de Saint-Ouen comme une voisine
ou vie maintenant la famille les parents
ont été identifiés comme étant les
principaux responsables des
interpellations virulentes et du climat
de pression instaurée depuis le
printemps dernier à l'encontre de
l'équipe pédagogique souvent en fait le
conflit n'est de petites broutilles du
quotidien mais pour lesquelles parce que
on est dans un collectif et que le vivre
ensemble dans une école il est essentiel
les enseignantes la directrice d'école
se doivent de prendre des décisions pour
réguler des petits conflits du quotidien
et sauf que parfois on en arrive à des
situations de famille qui n'admettent
pas une décision qui est prise par la
directrice d'école qui a tout à fait le
droit de prendre cette décision là la
décision de radiation qui devrait
prendre effet très vite devrait
permettre de débloquer la situation et
pourquoi pas un retour des quatre
enseignantes dès lundi le maire de
Vendôme et la directrice académique
devrait chacun rencontrer la famille
d'ici la fin de la semaine